Do you know that moment when someone
tells you your history is a gift,
that your ancestors' suffering was
actually good for you, and you can't find
the words to respond?
It's not just insulting, it's the same
lie that justifies
why 46 of 49 protesters
were killed in indigenous
regions of Peru in 2022 and 2023.
I'll show you exactly how
a 500-year-old Spanish lie
connects directly to bullets fired in my
wife's hometown, with
receipts from over 40 academic
sources. My wife's from Juliaca, Peru.
She is indigenous. I
live with her in Ayacucho.
Last year in Lima, a Spanish Airbnb owner
told us that she should be
grateful for colonization,
that Spain brought civilization, freed
her people from
oppression, gave them rights.
I froze, I knew it was wrong, but I
didn't have the evidence to prove it.
Millions believe this.
In Peru, people tell my wife she's
"mejorar la raza",
improving her race by being with me.
But there's something about these claims
that most people get completely backward.
The Spanish said they brought
civilization to cannibals and
savages. Your first instinct
might be to argue the Incas were in
cannibals. But that's the
wrong approach. The real question
is why Spanish reports suddenly started
calling everyone cannibals
after 1503. Columbus created
the word cannibal by conflating Caribbean
peoples called "canniba"
with eating human flesh based
more on imagination than observation. But
why? Because in 1503, a
bull said you could legally
enslave one specific group, cannibals.
Suddenly, every group that
resisted became cannibals in
Spanish reports. It wasn't anthropology,
it was a business model.
For Peru, the Incas explicitly
shunned eating human flesh.
Archaeological digs found, and I quote,
"nothing approaching the
thousands of victims" the Spanish
claimed. But here's what
the Spanish actually found.
Felipe Guamán Poma de Ayala, Quechua
nobleman, spent 15 years
documenting what he saw.
1,189 pages, 398 hand-drawn illustrations
showing Spanish officials
beating indigenous women,
workers driven to mines, and priests
demanding sexual favors.
The Incas were sophisticated.
They governed 9 million people, built
5,000 kilometers of road
networks that some Spanish
chroniclers admitted were finer than
ancient Rome. They created
earthquake-proof architecture
without mortar. The Indian peoples had
three fundamental
principles. Amasua, don't steal,
amalola, don't lie, and amacrila, don't
be lazy. The Spanish violated all three.
They stole 24 tons of gold from Atahualpa
alone. They lied about
providing protection, and
they forced indigenous people into brutal
labor while extracting wealth. The
Spanish didn't bring
civilization. They destroyed it. The
Spanish destroyed the most
sophisticated civilization
in South America. They turned those exact
regions into extraction
zones. 500 years later,
those same regions are still being
targeted. That's not
coincidence. That's continuity.
But maybe you're thinking the Incas were
not angels. They had forced labor too.
Doesn't that make the Spanish liberation
partially true? This
is where it gets dark.
November 1532, Pizarro's trap closes.
Atahualpa is captured.
He offers his tourists
riches to ransom. He would fill a room 24
feet long, 18 feet wide,
and 8 feet high with gold.
He delivers 24 tons of gold and silver.
The Spanish take it, and
then they put him on trial
for treason against Spain, a country he
had never been to. July
26th, 1533, they execute him. But
that was just the beginning. The Spanish
took the Inca mita,
rotational community labor where
the state fed you, and they turned it
into this. Potosi, a Spanish friar,
called it a "mouth of
hell." 13,500 men forced annually to work
at altitude, underground,
50-degree heat, 300-pound
loads. Conservative scholars estimate
over one million dead at
Potosi alone. Mercury poisoning
killed a third of workers. Highland
provinces lost 60% of their
population. When Tupacamaro II
rebelled against this system in 1780,
Spain killed up to
100,000 indigenous people. But
indigenous people never stopped
resisting. Peru went from 9 million
people to 600,000 in one
century. 90% dead. That's not liberation.
That's the worst
demographic disaster in human history.
The Spanish love citing their protective
laws, like the new laws of
1542. But here's what they
don't tell you. When Viceroy Blasco
Núñez Vela arrived to
enforce them, the Spanish colonists
beheaded him, the king revoked the laws.
But let's say you believe
Spain tried. When did indigenous
Peruvians actually receive rights? Peru
gained independence in 1821.
Forced labor ended 148 years
later. Quechua recognized as an official
language 154 years after
independence. And the right to be
consulted about mining on their land 190
years after independence. Today, an
indigenous Peruvian needs
80% more job applications for the same
interview. Life
expectancy is 20 years lower.
December 2022, Pedro Castillo, Peru's
first rural provincial president, gets
removed from office.
Protests erupt. January 9th, 2023,
Ruyaca, my wife's hometown. 18
people are killed in one day.
In total, 49 people end up dead. 39 shot.
The police confiscated
zero firearms from protesters.
Human Rights Watch found no protesters
with guns in 37 hours of
footage. The new President
Bolivartes' response, "Pueno is not
Peru." So why do Spanish people and
Peruvian elites still believe
these lies? Spanish intellectuals created
the white legend,
claiming their colonization was
uniquely benevolent. Spain was
stigmatized in Europe for
mixing with morse and juice.
When they mixed with indigenous peoples,
it confirmed European prejudices about
Spanish racial impurity. So they created
mestizaje, were all mixed
as defense and hierarchy
simultaneously. And Spain still defends
this today. In 2019,
Mexico's president asked Spain
to apologize for colonial abuses. Spain's
response, "The arrival of Spaniards
cannot be judged in the
light of contemporary considerations." In
other words, genocide can't
be judged by today's moral
standards. That's Spain's official
position. Spain still
celebrates October the 12th as
"Day of Ispanidad," celebrating the
beginning of colonization. But let's be
clear about how this
mixing actually happened. Most of this
mixing in the first century of
colonization happened through
rape. Indigenous women had no choice.
Spanish men claimed right of conquest
over women's bodies,
just like they claimed the land. Today
they package this violence as
"we're all beautifully mixed."
They tell my wife she is improving her
race, as if the original
mixing was voluntary, as if it
wasn't trauma passed down through
generations. They turned evidence of rape
into a national identity,
then told the descendants to be grateful.
They're rebranding
sexual violence as progress,
just like they rebranded extraction as
development and genocide as civilization.
Scholar Marisol de la Cadena documented
how it works. "You improve
your race by accumulating
money, going to expensive university,
moving neighborhoods,
forgetting where you come from.
Indigenous people must commit
de-Indianization to escape
discrimination. And here's how the lie
reproduces itself. A Colombian friend
went to a Catholic school founded in
1604. Four centuries
later, they're still teaching that
Columbus brought
civilization. No mention of genocide,
no mention of slavery, no mention of
rape. The schools themselves
are colonial infrastructure,
still functioning, still lying. That's
not education, that's
indoctrination that's been
running for 400 years."
Peruvian sociologist Aníbal Quijano
called this "coloniality."
Colonial structure surviving after
colonialism ends. Colonial
power doesn't die. It survives.
It adapts. A 2021 economic history study
proved former Mita
districts still have worse outcomes
400 years later. They are the poorest
regions today. The same
regions where protesters died in
2022 were 75% of victims in Peru's 1980
to 2000 conflict were
Quechua speakers. The extraction
never stopped. It just changed
management. In 2024, archaeologists
scanned 179,000 square kilometers
of the Andes using satellite AI. 95% of
grid cells show no
archaeological traces. Where
indigenous communities once thrived, now
just emptiness. That
emptiness is colonial disruption
visible from space. The Spanish brought
three things to Peru. Death
for 90% of the population,
extraction that continues today, and lies
about both. And these
lies aren't unique to Peru.
The same schools, the same improvement
through rape rebranded as mixing, the
same violence against
those who resist are taught in Bogota,
Mexico City and Santiago.
500 years of resistance from
Atahualpa to Túpac Amaru to the protesters
in 2023. The same fight, the same
regions, the same refusal
to accept a lie. Share this with anyone
who thinks colonization was civilizing.
The sources are below.
And if you want more evidence-based
takedowns of historical propaganda,
subscribe. History versus
hype. Evidence beats
mythology every single time.